i go viral for basically anything you
know
nicki minaj doing her best adele
impression and get this she even sings a
little too
i wish nothing but the best for you
it all went down during carpool karaoke
with james corden the first installment
of the beloved segment in two years oh
thank you so much for helping me get to
work i really appreciate it my pleasure
thank you
but og fans will recall back in 2016
adele gave us this flawless rendition of
the rapper's verse on the hit monster
fast forward to 2022
and now it's nikki's turn in the hot
seat and she's giving us her best adele
i go viral for basically anything you
know what i mean like i sit down at the
basketball game right i don't look at
the camera i go i do one of these
numbers
i'm i'm viral do you know what i mean
but it doesn't end there nikki also
flexes her vocal chops and gives us an
adele classic don't forget me
epic
i remember
you said
sometimes it lasts in love but sometimes
it hurts instead
barbs around the world agree the only
thing we need now is that collab adele
made me swear to secrecy that i'm not
allowed to tell anyone that i'm working
with her and we already shot a video and
it's an epic song okay
sadly nikki later confirmed she was just
kidding but we've still got our fingers
crossed
yes and yes yes yes
back to carpool karaoke we got a bit of
new music i don't care how long it takes
to get back on outside [ __ ] we out back
and some throwbacks
[Music]
my anaconda don't want none unless
you've got buns honey
oh my
but something we didn't expect to see
nicki minaj the clarinet plate
oh
oh my god
that was like jaws
[Music]
wow you just played the soundtracks of
choice i'm amazing i told you and while
most of the segment was full of laughs
and silly moments nikki got serious for
a second while discussing pressure and
anxiety i think when you are a woman and
you're in the public eye all the time
you
if you're not careful you can become
less confident because you're being
constantly scrutinized you know and
i just don't think it's natural it's not
a natural for a human being
to just
always feel like everyone's critiquing
them as for how nikki copes well she
says becoming a mom in 2020 was a game
changer when i look at my son
i'm like just magically in love you know
he just makes me laugh makes me smile
makes me happy like it's just so cute
and cuddly from getting personal to
celebrity impressions and belting out
some hits safe to say carpel karaoke is
back with a bag they need rappers like
me they need rappers
[Applause]
[Music]
you